Hi, I'm Rich Fulcher,
a designer and manager
on the Android design
team here at Google.
At this year's
Google I/O conference
we introduced material design.
A new visual
language for creating
bold graphic interfaces driven
by typography, scale, color,
and position.
For me, one of the most exciting
things about material design
is how it takes these classic
principles of print design
and brings them to life.
The materials take energy from
the user, from their finger,
from their mouse click, their
touch and they take that energy
and use it to transform
and to animate.
Today, I'm going
to talk about how
these virtual materials
of paper and ink
pack much more power
than their real world
meatspace counterparts.
Now every pixel
drawn by an app is
a dot of ink on
a piece of paper.
Paper has no color, but
ink can be any color,
and ink coloring is how
all content is displayed,
whether that's the
controls of your app,
an image, or even a
video that's playing.
Paper can be a variety
of widths, the x-axis,
and heights, the y-axis.
It can even fill the
entire display, such
that you can't see the
edges of that paper,
or it could shrink down to just
be the size of a single button,
you know, no larger than a 48
by 48 dpi square touch target
or standard target sizes.
Ink doesn't have any
of those restrictions.
It can be any size, so long
as it fits within that paper.
You've got to have something
to actually apply that ink to
so that it can be seen.
Paper has an absolute
fixed thickness of 1 dpi.
That's equivalent to a 35
pound weight piece of paper,
so kind of a light card stock.
Now when you add ink, you're
not changing that thickness.
This isn't a kind
of paint that's
building up layer and layer
and layer and making it
thicker and thicker.
The paper itself is always that
1 dpi thick, it's never zero.
That would be a hologram.
And this isn't hollow,
this is material.
That sense of
tactility is vitally
important to the system.
In terms of shapes, paper wants
to be a rounded rectangle,
whether that's a
rectangle, or a square,
or even a circle, which
is just a really, really,
really rounded rectangle.
It doesn't want
to be a triangle.
It doesn't want to be a
concave shape, like a star,
or the shape of your app icon.
Now ink doesn't have
these restrictions.
It can be any shape
and it can cover
all those things
you want it to be.
Those are the basic
principles, but how
do all these materials
live and move
within a more complex structure.
Well, we need to start
by talking about depth,
and that means
embracing the z-axis.
Now every device has
a physical z-depth.
For a handheld device,
it's that distance
between the glass on the front
and the back of the device
that rests on the
palm of your hand.
Now that depth controls
how paper can behave,
so paper wants to respect
that devices depth.
It doesn't want to
be able to flip over
because if it were to do
a move like that well,
that paper is going
to start to move
it's going to bonk against
that glass on the front
of the device or against
the metal on the back.
You can't execute that move
and maintain that sense
for the user that it's
inside that device.
Just between those
front back slots.
That's why we don't
do paper flips.
When we have paper
it casts a shadow
and that shadow is based
on its position within z.
Now paper is generally
presented as square to the user.
Just like I'm moving my
hand back and forth in front
the camera here.
Paper moves to the users
eye in the same fashion.
Now paper will cast a shadow
when two pieces of paper
slightly overlap, like that.
One in front has a light
source in front of it,
the paper behind it isn't
getting all of that,
so it's getting a
shadow on the back.
We like to keep
the paper square.
We like to make sure that the
shadow isn't something that's
being drawn as ink, that's
being printed on the paper.
It comes about because of
the physical relationship,
because of the lighting model
that the system gives you.
When we have paper, it's solid.
When the user reaches
out and touches it,
the user can never
press through the paper.
It just kind of makes
contact and it's there.
Now we do respond to the user
in a couple of ways though.
One is that as the user
approaches the paper
and they make that
touch, the paper
will rise to kind of meet them.
So there's this illusion of the
glass here, your finger comes
down on the glass and the paper
completes that motion by coming
forward to meet
the user's finger.
You might think about it
as imagine your finger
kind of pointing down on a
reflecting surface of water
and as you get closer and
closer it sees it's reflection,
and those two touch together.
The way that ink responds
is like the ripples that
would happen on
the water, as I hit
that surface I break the
surface tension of the water,
I get this pleasant circular
rippling that occurs out of it.
That's what we do in the ink
to kind of communicate that
not just that you've made
contact with the paper,
but which of the particular
elements, ink elements
on the paper you've touched.
Now motion is all about
establishing and emphasizing
the continuity of
important elements,
and the paper to move across
any of those three axes.
We can move along x, it can
move along y, even along the z.
Now material can
do more than move.
Part of the magic of the
experience comes from a way
that materials can change.
The ways that they're not bound
by these boring physical laws
of the known universe.
So paper can change its size
in both the x and y position.
And ink can do its
own thing, it doesn't
have to do exactly
what the papers doing.
So you can do things like to
have a piece of paper resize,
and have the ink remain the same
size but just re-flow to take
advantage of that new
spacious real estate.
Or you could expand and have
the ink expand at the same rate.
Or you could leave the
paper at a fixed size
and have the ink just grow
or shrink within that.
They're completely independent.
Now you can change the width
and height of paper differently.
They don't have to be symmetric,
they can be asymmetric.
And that's really important
for when we do transformations.
We strongly encourage this.
So in the example over
here that you're seeing,
you are seeing tall objects
be made to feel taller.
Your seeing wide
objects made more broad.
Now why is this
asymmetry important?
Well it helps the
user understand
the difference between something
that's resizing and staying
in that place, and something
that's moving within z.
If I move within z, that's kind
of the same as symmetric scale,
as you get closer is growing in
both aspects at the same rate.
By doing re-sizes
asymmetrically,
we're letting the user know
OK, that content is actually
staying up at that same z level.
The movement is a
different signal to them.
Now paper can change
between its shapes,
but it does like to kind
of start at and return
to those core shapes
we talked about
before, those
rounded rectangles.
And like some kind
of x mutant paper,
paper can split or can
join, those materials can
heal together, they
can regenerate,
they can kind of
connect back up.
Creating or destroying paper is
always associated with motion.
Now paper can enter and
exit in different ways.
Those can be independent.
There's three main styles.
You could just kind of
create paper in place
and destroy it in place, you
can have it enter one way
and exit a different
way, or you can actually
have paper kind of
clone, so there's
one piece of paper clones and
creates a second one which
can then move, and then
it can rest back down
and heal and just become
one piece of paper again.
So how do multiple pieces of
paper interact with each other?
There's two key types
of arrangements.
The first are seams,
which are created
when two pieces of paper share
the full width of an edge.
It's like they're stitched
together at a common side.
Now when papers meet at a
seam and joins in that way,
it moves together.
They're actually connected
so they'll move as one.
The other is a step.
When we have two pieces of paper
with different z positions that
overlap and you get that
shadow we talked about, then
you've created a step.
These two papers don't have
a relationship to each other.
So they can move independently
one of the other.
A very common way
that we'll see a step
is for a toolbar, where you have
a step above a larger, usually
a larger, sheet of paper
the can slide under it.
Now there are variants to this.
You might start with the toolbar
and the other piece of paper
seamed together and have the
toolbar just rise within z,
just as it needs to accommodate
the motion underneath,
so it could lift to make room.
Or you can reverse that, it
could move backwards in z
and the other piece of paper
could come up and cover it.
Or finally, you could just kind
of leave them seamed together.
The other piece of paper
pushes a toolbar up
and it just pops off
and then you only
see the other piece
of paper present.
When paper passes
over a toolbar,
it's important
that you not split
any of the actions
the toolbar might
contain with a piece of paper.
You want to make sure
that the actions are
on one side or the other.
And one last note
about toolbars,
just like any piece of
paper, they can resize.
So they can start
tall and as the user
scrolls they can shrink up,
or you can reverse that motion
as they move the other way.
The one thing you'll
want to keep in mind
is that it's best have the
toolbar snap between those two
positions.
Instead of just getting
stuck in that middle ground
between them, you want
to kind of crisply move
to the smaller or larger sizes.
Another signature
element in paper
is the floating action button.
We nickname it the FAB.
A FAB can straddle a seam if it
relates to the content of both
of the pieces of paper that
are meeting at that seam,
or it can straddle a step if it
relates to the piece of paper
that's creating the step, the
one that's more forward in z.
Now, you don't have
to put in a FAB,
a straddle point
like that, it doesn't
have to be on a seam or step.
It could just be on
a piece of paper,
conveniently tucked away in
a corner, or really anywhere
within that paper surface.
And you want to avoid
doing things like,
artificially creating
a seam or step,
just to give your
FAB a place to live.
Those seam and
step relationships
should be about the structure
in the inner-relationship
of those pieces of material.
Not about just having
a decorative point.
If you want to learn
more, our guidelines
are a great place to start.
If you go to
www.google.com/design
or specifically /spec, you can
read about all of our material
design guidelines, and you'll
see a bunch of examples that
can help you get
started with this.
There are also a ton of
resources there waiting
for you to download them,
sticker sheets, templates,
icons, even fonts are available
for you from that side.
Thanks for watching
and I hope you
have a lot of fun
designing with material.